Americans need to pay attention to the
civil war inside of Yemen because its
development has ramifications for
American national security interests. The
country is home to al Qaeda in the
Arabian Peninsula, one of al Qaeda's most
virulent affiliates. It has attacked the
United States over three times since its
founding in 2009, and there is also a small
ISIS presence. But more importantly, today,
is the way that Yemen has affected our
Gulf partners. Saudi Arabia is now
embroiled in the war in Yemen. Saudi
Arabia cannot risk having a destabilized
Yemeni state on its southern
border, and it will continue to distract the
country, even as the United States asks the
Saudi's to step up increasingly inside
of Syria. It's not just the Saudis who are
involved in Yemen. The Emiratis have also
deployed a significant task force inside
of the country to assist in
counterterrorism operations. The
deployment inside of Yemen means that
our Gulf Arab partners do not have the
military to support our efforts inside
of Syria, and therefore the United States
needs to care about what is going on in
the war in Yemen.
Should the U.S. support its regional partners in Yemen? If so, how?
Let us know in the comments section, and
let us know what other topics you want
AEI scholars to cover in 60 seconds.